The world of Pokemon is a bright, colorful
place full of unusual animals.
And if you're anything like the average gamer,
you've spent hundreds of hours wandering through
the wilderness, looking for Pocket Monsters
to fight, kidnap, and train to battle for
you.
It's a vicious cycle, and that underlying
weirdness has given rise to some of the strangest,
creepiest video game bootlegs and mods of
any series out there.
After seeing these Pokemon bootlegs, we're
not sure if you'll want to catch 'em all.
Pokemon “Creepy” Black
The bizarre rumor of Pokemon “Creepy”
Black first popped up around 2005 when someone
supposedly found an all-black Game Boy cart
at a flea market.
The game gives you the option to start out
with your standard Pokemon, but you can also
start out with Ghost, a Pokemon that can do
only one thing: instantly terrify other Pokemon
and trainers to death.
By the end of the game, your trusty Ghost
turns on you, and you too are dragged into
the cold, cold ground.
As with most online horror stories, Pokemon
“Creepy” Black probably wasn't a legit
cart, but the weird Internet story inspired
multiple modders to bring the game to life
in ROM form.
Download it if you'd like a sleepless night
or two, pondering the ethics of being a Pokemon
trainer.
Just watch out for those Ghost-types.
The creepy doesn’t stop there, however...
Hypno's Lullaby
A mod that arose from a creepypasta poem,
Hypno's Lullaby is all about the strange,
hypnotic Pokemon and his secret penchant for
kidnapping small children and bringing them
to his cave in Berry Forest.
One could argue that every single Pokemon
deserves a bit of revenge for how they're
treated by their trainers, and Hypno's Lullaby
exacts that revenge tenfold.
Your hero really has no option but to grab
a starter Pokemon and wander into the woods,
where you're immediately captured by Hypno
and trapped in a cave with other zonked-out
kids.
As you work your way out of the cave, you
can only order your Pokemon to kill Hypno's
juvenile slaves, who block every exit.
Then, you work your way through a tower full
of unbeatable ghosts and the spirits of children
you've killed.
Eventually, Hypno throws one last barrage
of children at you before trapping you in
a room where he eats your dreams for all eternity.
There is no end; you just shut off the game
and quietly walk away, telling no one what
you’ve done.
There’s even more for you, however, if you
like your Pokemon full of death and despair.
Pokemon Snakewood
Pokemon Ruby is a popular Pokemon game to
mod, and Pokemon Snakewood is just one strange
example of the results.
Snakewood crosses Pokemon with The Walking
Dead.
The result is a game in a post-apocalyptic
setting populated by zombies and demons, where
even the Pokemon have adorably creepy names
like Poliwraith and Headoom.
In true Walking Dead style, your hero wakes
up in a destroyed town, encounters someone
being attacked by zombies, and finds a safe
zone.
As you play, you eventually battle the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse, which is a lot
scarier than just battling some spoiled kid
who likes forcing animals to fight one another.
It's a surprisingly robust story for an unofficial
game.
Snakewood proves that Pokemon has its fair
share of inventive—and weird—fans.
Pokemon Quartz
Do you love the concept of Pokemon but hate
all of those corporate, Nintendo-approved
monsters?
Well, Pokemon Quartz may be the game for you.
Dedicated Pokemon bootleggers made a copy
of Ruby and replaced all of the official Pokemon
sprites with their own malformed creations.
While these Pocket Monsters' names and appearances
have changed, their powers and stats remain
intact.
Why have the Charmanders been replaced with
these?
Our best scientists are still working on an
answer.
Quartz is criticized for being relatively
amateurish and incomplete, but the visual
overhaul of so many lovable and popular Pokemon
is just so weirdly obsessive… and pointless...
that it can't be ignored.
Pokemon Sweet
Modded from FireRed, Pokemon Sweet reimagines
the entire world of Pokemon as a surreal,
Candy Kingdom-like place.
Here, everything is made of desserts, and
delicious danger lurks around every corner.
Because just walking around cotton candy fields
isn't enough, your favorite Pokemon, now called
Pokesweets, are now named after snacks.
Bulbasaur becomes Brownisaur and gets a dollop
of whipped cream and a cherry.
And Popsichu... has a giant wooden stick shoved
into its head.
Pokemon types are now flavors instead, and
you basically just ruined your dinner.
The deadliest attack in the game?
Diabetes.
Moemon Emerald / FireRed
For those who want their Pokemon experience
to be even weirder, Moemon is for you.
Moemon replaces all of those totally unattractive
monsters with sprites of cosplay girls dressed
up as Pokemon instead, raising even more ethical
questions than the original.
Because pitting animals in deathmatches against
one another isn't horrifying enough, you now
send costumed girls into the arena to fight
one another until one finally passes out from
the pain.
Instead of building your Pokemon collection,
you slowly grow a violent, confusing little
harem.
Pokemon AshGray
True Pokenerds know the differences between
the original Pokemon games and the anime of
the same name.
AshGray inventively tweaks the original game's
script and missions to actually follow the
events of the offshoot media, including many
episode-specific events, from giving donuts
to Primeapes to leaving Pikachu to live with
other Pikachu in the forest.
The result is a carton of Easter eggs for
devotees of the Pokemon universe, who may
have found the original games lacking after
seeing the more colorful anime.
If the cartoon isn’t your thing, however,
there are even more options for players who
want something more out of Pokemon than just
grinding for Gengars.
Pokemon Advanced Adventure
As far as narrative structure goes, the Pokemon
anime series is still pretty flimsy.
Ash doesn't have any real motivation to be
the best Pokemon trainer in the world, aside
from the fact that it's something to do in
a world without standardized education or
non-Pokemon-based employment opportunities.
Pokemon Advanced Adventure flips the script
and rewrites Ash as a kid struggling against
poverty, genetically modified Pokemon, and
Professor Oak's insane, tyrannical grandson
whose only purpose is to train Pokemon to
kill.
Finally, Ash is written as an actual hero,
and not just some animal hoarder with dozens
of neglected pets.
Pokemon Vietnamese Crystal
While most of these games are intentionally
strange, there are also a few examples that
are amazing by accident, like Pokemon Vietnamese
Crystal.
Fake Pokemon carts are a huge business, and
Kotaku reports that this was a genuine bootleg
that circulated in Vietnam before it was poorly
translated into English.
As a result, the game's text is hilarious:
it regularly drops profanity, calls Pokemon
"elves," and barely attempts to make sense.
Since it's just a mistranslated Pokemon game
without any big changes, it plays just fine,
if you can make the right text selections
through the garbled menus and figure out what
the game means by phrases like "volcano bakemeat"...
which kinda sounds exactly like something
Guy Fieri would serve.
2003 Pocket Monster Carbuncle
Unlike most Pokemon bootlegs, which just tweak
existing code, 2003 Pocket Monster Carbuncle
actually attempts some originality, according
to a GeekParty review.
The resulting game plays a bit like the classic
NES Dragon Warrior, but also reduces the number
of Pokemon to 20, tossing biodiversity out
the window.
The word "carbuncle" usually refers to a cluster
of boils, which would be appropriate enough
for this game, but it's also an obscure word
for a red gemstone, which fits in with Pokemon's
recurring theme of naming games after fancy
rocks.
Unfortunately, 2003 Pocket Monster Carbuncle
is a garbage game, and it doesn't play like
Pokemon in any sense whatsoever, but points
for trying something new, unknown foreign
plagiarizers!
Pocket Monsters GO!
GO!
Now, we enter the realm of the truly terrible.
For no reason whatsoever, other than to dupe
unsuspecting Pokemon fans, some horrible soul
switched out sprites from The Smurfs' Nightmare
for Game Boy Color, made it run at half speed,
and pretended it was a Pokemon game.
Even the most lonely fanfic writers never
asked for a Smurfs/Pokemon crossover, but
anything is possible when you have no friends.
Starting off your adventure, you’re greeted
by a talking Meowth head who rambles the following:
"Every night in my dreams I see you, I feel
you.
You are here so I very fear.
There is some hate that will not go away."
Then, you send your morbidly obese Pikachu
through some kind of Satan Town with flickering,
seizure-inducing backgrounds.
You then quickly pull the cart out of your
Game Boy and throw it across the room before
it's too late.
Pokemon Stadium: Super Nintendo Edition
Despite Pokemon's relentless popularity, there
was never an official game made for the original
Nintendo Entertainment System or the Super
Nintendo.
In fact, the first major Pokemon game for
consoles was the Nintendo 64's Pokemon Stadium,
so it makes little sense to reverse engineer
an N64 cartridge to an older gaming system.
The SNES was pretty outdated by this time,
so making bootlegs of imaginary games wasn’t
really economically viable.
It's like trying to sell a fake dial-up modem;
even if it’s real, no one needs one anymore.
Much like the real Pokemon Stadium, the SNES
bootleg is a turn-based fighter, but with
a limited roster of twelve Pokemon.
They all have incorrect names: Diglett is
Dagut, Mewtwo is Mu, and Jigglypuff is Pulin.
It's a fully functional game, unlike most
bootlegs, but it's a step in the wrong direction,
just like the final game in our list...
Pokemon 4-in-1
Another relic from the age of the original
Nintendo, Pokémon 4-in-1 is one of those
terrible anthology games that crams four games
onto a cart to apologize for all of them sucking.
And again, because the Nintendo Entertainment
System was becoming a thing of the past by
the time Pokémon was popular, this is just
weird.
The game includes Picaclick, where you click
on groups of matching symbols; Picadance,
where you tap on Pokéballs in time to a song;
Picaslot, which is a slot machine for amateur
gamblers, and…
Pac-Man.
Which is Pac-Man, but with a disembodied Pikachu
head.
Every single aspect of this is a waste of
money and time, but because it’s bizarre
and obscure, Pokecollectors will sell their
Pokekidneys to get their hands on one.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
bootleg Pokemon game you think is the weirdest...